practiquemos un poco más las
proyecciones de newman nos piden que
veamos este compuesto desde el enlace
entre el carbono 3 y 4 y dibujemos la
conformación más estable entonces
primero vamos a enumerar los carbonos
este es el carbono 1 2 3 4 5 y 6 si
observamos el compuesto desde el enlace
entre el carbono 3 y 4
es decir si ponemos nuestros ojos por
aquí en un momento les mostraré un vídeo
pero es importante que podamos dibujar
las proyecciones de newman sin usar un
modelo molecular entonces primero
pensemos en lo que está unido al carbono
3 tenemos un grupo metilo hacia nosotros
lo que significa que hay un hidrógeno
lejos de nosotros
y que está unido al carbono 4 bueno
tenemos un hidrógeno hacia nosotros aquí
tenemos un hidrógeno y también tenemos
un hidrógeno lejos de nosotros entonces
una vez que dibujamos esto podemos
dibujar nuestra proyección de newman
lo primero que dibujamos es nuestro
punto que representa al carbono 3 el
carbono frontal y unido al carbono 3
tenemos un grupo metilo hacia abajo y
hacia la derecha si ponemos nuestros
ojos aquí lo que vemos es un grupo
metilo hacia abajo y hacia la derecha
así que tenemos un ch 3 hacia aquí
también tenemos un hidrógeno hacia abajo
y hacia la izquierda
después tenemos un h 2c h 3 un grupo de
tilo si observamos la molécula desde
esta perspectiva el grupo de tilo va
hacia arriba entonces hacia arriba
tenemos un ch tos ch3 ahora el carbono 4
es de carbono no lo podemos ver porque
nos tapa el carbono 3 pero lo podemos
representar con un círculo
unido al carbono 4 tenemos un hidrógeno
hacia arriba y hacia la derecha vamos a
dibujarlo también tenemos un hidrógeno
hacia arriba y hacia la izquierda
ahí está finalmente tenemos un ch 2 ch 3
hacia abajo entonces tenemos de h2 h3 y
para no escribir todo vamos a redibujar
la proyección como sea chetos ch3 es un
grupo estilo vamos a abreviar lo como
este y al grupo metilo lo abreviar hemos
como m
después tenemos un hidrógeno por aquí y
en nuestro carbono de atrás tenemos un
hidrógeno de este lado
un hidrógeno por acá y un grupo de tilo
hacia abajo en el vídeo que les mostraré
el grupo de tilo será de color rojo
el grupo metilo será de color azul
notarán que es más fácil ver las
conformaciones de esta manera en el
vídeo veremos cuál es la conformación
más estable como ya sabemos será una
conformación alternada así que veamos
las diferentes conformaciones alternadas
y determinemos cuál es la más estable
aquí tenemos el carbono 1 carbono 2
carbono 3 y observen que tenemos un
grupo metilo hacia nosotros y este es el
carbono 4 observaremos el enlace entre
el carbono 3 y 4 si giramos la molécula
esta es la conformación alternada arriba
tenemos un grupo estilo del lado derecho
tenemos un metilo
abajo tenemos otro grupo de tilo espero
que puedan ver la conformación alternada
esta esfera roja representa a un grupo
de tilo y aquí tenemos otro el azul
representa al grupo metilo es más fácil
así partimos de esta conformación y
cuando rotamos el carbono frontal sin
mover el carbono de atrás nos queda otra
conformación y si rotamos obtenemos otra
conformación alternada observen que la
proyección de newman que dibujamos
coincide con la fotografía del vídeo
esta es la misma proyección de newman
sólo que representamos los grupos de
tilo de color rojo y el metilo de color
azul en el vídeo lo que hicimos fue
rotar el carbono frontal sin mover el
carbono de atrás a este grupo estilo
rojo lo movimos a esta posición con lo
que el grupo metilo azul se movió hacia
acá
y finalmente este hidrógeno de color
verde se movió a esta posición
corresponde a este hidrógeno dibujemos
la siguiente conformación alternada como
el carbono de atrás permanece igual
vamos a redibujar lo unido al carbono de
atrás tenemos dos hidrógenos y este
grupo de tilo ahora en el carbono
frontal
el grupo de tilo se movió a esta
posición el grupo metilo quedó aquí y el
hidrógeno quedó por acá observen que
esto coincide con la fotografía tenemos
dos grupos de tilo muy cerca respecto al
otro por acá tenemos el grupo metilo
azul y el hidrógeno verde es este
hidrógeno y podemos rotar nuevamente
para obtener la última conformación
alternada
este grupo de ti lo puede rotar a esta
posición con lo que el grupo metilo se
mueve hasta aquí y el hidrógeno verde
rota a esta posición entonces primero
dibujamos el carbono de atrás que tiene
dos hidrógenos y un grupo de tilos
no importa si rotamos el carbono frontal
o el de atrás yo preferí rotar el
carbono frontal ahora nos queda con un
grupo de tilos en esta posición después
tenemos el grupo metilo hacia arriba y
el hidrógeno queda hacia este lado
entonces estos son nuestros grupos de
tilos que corresponden a estos
este es nuestro metilo azul y este es
nuestro hidrógeno verde
ahora cuál es la conformación alternada
más estable bueno pensemos en las
interacciones coach por ejemplo en esta
conformación de la derecha tenemos una
interacción coach estilo estilo los
grupos de tilos son muy voluminosos y
eso desestabiliza la conformación ahora
analicemos está aquí tenemos otra
interacción coach entre dos grupos
estilos pero también tenemos una
interacción entre un grupo estilo y un
metilo entonces como tenemos dos
interacciones coach en esta conformación
eso significa que es más inestable
finalmente analicemos esta conformación
aquí sólo tenemos una interacción gose
entre un grupo estilo y un metilo pero
como el grupo metilo no es tan
voluminoso como un estilo eso significa
que
esta es la conformación con más baja
energía es la más estable en el inciso b
nuestro objetivo es dibujar la
conformación menos estable es decir la
de más alta energía
así que dibujaremos una conformación
eclipsada en el vídeo empezaremos con
una conformación alternada y pasaremos a
una conformación eclipsada para poder
encontrar las demás y así podamos
determinar cuál es la conformación menos
estable aquí tenemos la conformación
alternada y si rotamos el carbono
frontal podemos ver una conformación
eclipsada
si la rotamos obtenemos otra
conformación donde los grupos de tilo
están muy cerca y si rotamos de nuevo
obtenemos la última conformación
eclipsada aquí tenemos las fotografías
de las tres con formaciones eclipsadas
vamos a analizarlas y luego dibujemos la
proyección de newman
con formación menos estable empecemos
con la conformación de la derecha aquí
podemos ver un grupo de tilo eclipsado
con un hidrógeno un grupo metilo
eclipsado con un hidrógeno y un
hidrógeno eclipsado con un etil como no
tenemos a ninguno de los grupos alquilo
eclipsados esta no es la conformación
menos estable lo que buscamos son grupos
voluminosos que se encuentren cerca es
decir que haya impedimento estético
ahora analicemos esta conformación
tenemos dos hidrógenos eclipsados un
grupo de tilo eclipsado con un hidrógeno
y un grupo metilo eclipsado con un
estilo aquí hay un aumento de energía
esta conformación es más alta en energía
que éste pero vamos a compararla con la
que tenemos en el centro
aquí tenemos dos grupos de tilo
eclipsados entre sí y eso es muy
inestable aumenta la energía entonces
esta es la conformación menos estable
porque estos grupos de tilo prefieren
estar lo más lejos posible del otro y
aquí se encuentran muy cerca entonces
dibujemos la proyección de newman para
esta conformación empecemos con este
carbón que lo representamos con un punto
y unido a este carbono tenemos un grupo
metilo hacia arriba y hacia la derecha
después tenemos un hidrógeno hacia
arriba y hacia la izquierda
y luego tenemos un grupo de tilo hacia
abajo
para el carbono de atrás que lo
representamos con un círculo hacia
arriba y hacia la izquierda
tenemos un hidrógeno después tenemos
otro hidrógeno por aquí y finalmente
tenemos un grupo de tilo hacia abajo
esta es nuestra conformación menos
estable que es una conformación
eclipsada dibujada en la proyección de
newman